now this is objectively definitively you
have to answer one person who's the
greatest president in american history
oh that's easy yeah abraham lincoln
is that easy not george washington um
you know washington had his uh had the
statesman qualities he understood his
power as as uh as the first president
also relinquished power he was willing
to relinquish power
he you know
but
but lincoln has the combination of
personal leadership
um a fundamental moral character
and um and just the ability to kind of
uh to fight the the fight of politics to
play the game of it and to get where
he's going to play the short game and
the long game
um to kind of you know make to
uh you know to work with his enemies to
to block them when he had to
um and you know i mean he
gets the united states through the civil
war so you got to give him some credit
for that and it's pretty good at making
speeches
uh it you know obviously it helps that
he's a
a remarkable speaker um and able to
convey those kinds of visions um but um
you know but it but he is first and
foremost a politician and probably the
best one we have
both getting elected and ruling
in some ways better
better at the doing than at the getting
elected right um you know that he uh
you know the election of 1860 is a it's
just a hot mess um you know that that
could have worked out
many different ways and even the
election of 1864
you know when we have a presidential
election in the middle of a civil war
um it was not a foregone conclusion that
lincoln would be re-elected um so you
know both times he's sort of
um
you know he's not a a master campaigner
um by by any means but he he was a
master uh politician as a as a governor
do we have leaders like that today
is that so one perspective is like
leaders aren't
ain't what they used to be
and another perspective is well we
always romanticize stuff that happens in
the past
we forget the flaws and remember the
great moments
yeah uh both of those things are true
right um on the one hand um
you know we we don't uh we are not
surrounded by people of of lincoln's
caliber um right now
that feels like the case um and i think
that i think we can say that with some
certainty
but um
you know i always like to point to
president harry truman who
left office with you know some truly
abysmal
uh presidential ratings
was dismissed as a throughout his
presidency as a you know as a
as unqualified as not knowing what he
was doing etc and then you know turns
out um
with hindsight we know that he was
better at the job than anyone understood
better at getting elected right you
remember that sign dewey defeats truman
right he showed them right and better
better at holding power and better at
sort of
you know kind of building the kind of
institutions that long after he was gone
um demonstrated that he he
he won the long game
and some of that is the victor's do
right
the story and
i ask myself very much how will history
remember vladimir zelinski
it's not obvious
and how will history remember putin
that too
is not obvious
because it depends on how
the role the geopolitics
the
how the nations how the history of these
nations unravel unfold rather
so
it's very interesting to think about and
the same is true for
donald trump joe biden
obama
george bush
bill clinton
and so on
i think it's a probably unanswerable
question of which of the presidents will
be remembered as a great president from
this time
you can make all kinds of cases for all
kinds of people and they do but it's
unclear it's fascinating to think about
when the robots finally take over
what which of the humans they will
appreciate the most
you